we're glad you've joined us for this
live webinar understanding
immunosuppressive myeloid cells and
immunotherapy using the proteome profile
or antibody array I am Judy O'Rourke of
Labatt's and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by bio
techne bio technique corporation is a
leading developer and manufacturer of
high-quality purified proteins
antibodies immunoassays biologically
active small molecule compounds and
advanced cell Diagnostics in situ
hybridization detection products biotech
knees products are integral components
of scientific investigations into
biological processes and the nature and
progress of specific diseases for more
about biotech new place visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor please click on
the C tab at the top right and follow
the process to receive your credits you
can pose questions to the speaker during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind please note that biotech these
scientists Rachel Weller rasca and n a
report are available to answer questions
about the proteome profile or antibody
arrays used in this webinar simply type
your questions into the Q&A box
questions will be answered after the
presentation if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem through the Q&A box I now
presented a speaker shin Lew PhD the
John M and Mary Jo Buller assistant
professor of biology at the University
of Notre Dame dr. Lou develops novel
insights into the genetic and molecular
mechanisms of prostate tumor progression
tumor immunology and treatment
resistance his research team at the
University of Notre Dame in
Indiana University's Simon Cancer Center
is actively investigating the mechanisms
of myeloid cell regulation and targeting
in prostate cancer and other forms of
malignancy including rare cancers
through his PhD research at Princeton
University and postdoctoral research at
MD Anderson Cancer Center dr. Liu has
made many contributions toward
developing a mechanism mechanistic
understanding and identifying
therapeutic interventions for breast
cancer and prostate cancer he has
published more than 20 research and
review articles his complete bio
is found on the lab routes website in
this webinar dr. Liu will discuss how he
used antibody arrays to interrogate
signaling changes associated with
immunotherapy and animal models dr. Liu
will now begin his presentation
hello everybody our thank you so much
for the invitation and the introduction
again my name is ash in lieu I'm a
professor in Universal mm
today I will mainly talk about how to
use the proton profiler array to start a
cancer immunology and immunotherapy
you
so first I like to quickly go over my
laboratory at Notre Dame our research
goal is to develop a novel insights into
the genetic molecular and cellular
mechanisms of prostate cancer
progression include the other cancer
types as well as understanding of the
tumor mapping environment and the
treatment resistance by using those
knowledge we hope to develop and improve
with therapeutic interventions so
eventually we can benefit the cancer
patient so our focus is on prostate
cancer breast cancer but we also do a
few rare cancers because our lab belongs
to the center of rare and neglected
disease at another dam so the current is
central projects in the lab include are
done understanding the cancers are
intrinsic and extrinsic extrinsic
mechanism for immunosuppression and
immunotherapy resistance we also focus
on using genetic tools to understand the
tumor progression and also develop a
newly targeted new targeted therapies
against the cancer so my contact
information is here so if you interest
in further discussion or collaborations
after the top please contact me we
definitely welcome all kinds of
collaboration opportunities so today
we'll mainly for talk about the process
cancer as we all know frost cancer in
the Western world is the most of
frequently diagnosed malignancy for
American for Americans men and also
mainly Europe so I'll show it here about
18 19 percent of new cancer incidence
are depressed cancer and also it's the
third of leading cause of cancer
mortality for American myth
over the years there have been a lot of
stories trying to understand the
mechanisms of post-cancer of probation
but now we understand that frost cancer
can't derive from derived from the
normal prostate gland and then go
through some Christological account as
define the processes such as the early
prosthetic intraepithelial neoplasia -
original carcinoma and eventually become
attached bigger adenocarcinoma and that
during this process there has been
characteristic genetic and epigenetic
changes associated with with with the
steps for instance repeating activation
and they use a tool over expression
however despite these understanding the
current the strategies to target cancer
particularly the malignant metastasis
costumes resistant frost can sir
is very limited so this disease the C
RPC remain incurable or currently
so over the years the field opinion a
lot of knowledge about a tumor mapping
environment and how it plays a role to
regulate the different hallmarks of
cancer least that this diagram is the
famous cancer hallmarks that usually
proposed by dr. Weinberg Nahanni high
and recently revised to include
additional hallmarks and if you look
carefully and you actually see that the
the non cancer cells in the tumor monkey
environment which includes the
infiltrate immune cells the fibroblasts
and the vascular cells can regulate many
of these hallmarks
so they are very increasing the
appreciate to play more angels and also
modulate response to therapeutic and
today we mainly talk about this
particular population called myeloid
arrived suppress yourself or MDF sees so
many diverse the pestle itself is a
Hitler typic population of myeloid cells
that are induced by cancer or other
other diseases such as the acute
infection so this diagram shows both the
normal and abnormal differentiation
pathways for my life for my life self
the scene dotted lines here represent
the normal differentiation and you can
see that these cells come from the bone
marrow criminal party stem cells
originally and it become the progenitor
cells I just pretend your cells can
develop into a modified which become
macrophages after the uncertainties
resident issues and they also can
develop a differentiated into granular
sets including neutrophils basophils and
eosinophils they also can differentiate
into a dendritic cells those are those
are normal health itself in healthy
individuals
however in patients with cancer the
cytokines produced by either cancer
cells or other tumor cells pneumatic
environments can induce abnormal
differentiation pathways and a lot of
loss the progenitor cells actually are
held in such a human truth betters and
they are displayed as MDS seeds here it
shows that I'm the acid catalyst have
two subpopulations why it's called the
polymorphonuclear our MDS ii also known
as granular setting I'm Dan C because
the dermatology is similar to the
granule size another group of four MDS
is called the model statigram disease
because their morphology is more look
like a moun effects so both of these I'm
their depopulation can inhibit the T
cell activity through very different
kinds of mechanisms
so today my talk well we are focused on
understanding the function of immediacy
is Improv cancer and how we can target
them and particularly highlighting the
technical of the proteomic of provider
array so my research on cancer and MDS
II came from our earlier publications my
poster lab dr. round opinions lab at
immunity you know the lab publish the
papers from the eleven to show that we
developed up by the aggressive processor
model by profited specific deletion of
two tumor suppressor genes the p10 and
its metaphor so you can see that
compared to the PETA and single deletion
is double knockout of developer of
grassy process cancer very quickly and
those cancer eyes also metastases to
leave a note and too long and then by
looking at the histology of these tumors
of Lister bonaga tumors you quickly
realize they not only have a significant
increase the tumor cancer cells they
also have a lot of easy attrition of non
cancer cells and a lot of look like a
museum that was the earlier paper and
are subsequently collaborating with
another post on the lab dr. Wong we
profiled the tumors at different ages
for immunity mill effect and we see that
on the right you'll see that this red
colored pie chart I represent the city
11 p+ Chiara and positive MDS a
population they increased a lot over the
time of the mouse progression and then
under the flow cytometry also shows the
population of ideas in this mouse model
are mainly dominated by the
polymorphonuclear MD I see this is a
true across people lobe of the Prophet
the AAP the TRP and the VP shown at the
bottom
so those are phenotypic data and then I
wouldn't go into details of this paper
because what's published are more than
two one year ago so but basically in
this paper we demonstrate that the prof
cancer cells will activate a lapsed
reciben factor a Yap and t-80
interaction will drive the
transcriptional activation of the chemo
can called CX c l5 & CX l5o
secreted from cancer cells will recruit
the progenitor cells manually progenitor
cells which express the receptor called
as the X BR 2 from the bone marrow and
those cells will migrate into the tumor
parenchymal and then become those
functional er you know suppressive cells
known as MDS
so them dancing was suppressed the T
cells in the tumor at them and promote
tumor progression we feel we are treated
mice with some agents that can block MD
as a recruitment or activation such as a
ser tool inhibitor blocking the receptor
we were able to partially inhibit the
tumor progression in his model that was
the paper published in cancer discovery
however as I said we can all impartially
impair the tumor progression in this
model we can now to totally eradicate
lift over right
I will it study did bring onto the field
of cancer immunotherapy which we all
know it become very very exciting
recently due to a lot of clinical
devices of new immunotherapy Purex
particularly the MU checkpoint blockers
the no as I CBS to those who are ICP
agents such as unties to do it for and
anti PD biotech PDL one antibodies are
very important to reactivate the
cytotoxic t-cells the tumor Mac
environment so that those t-cells become
become reiterated and then display their
anti-cancer activity shown here are the
canonical understanding of how this
antibody work
however the metastasis ERP see the
Cartesian grid is improv cancer showed
overwhelmingly the noble resistance to
immune checkpoint blockade shown by
several publications but the question is
why mcrp sees resistance and also how
can we develop new strategies to reset
the ties those cancer types so they can
potentially be applied with the ICP
rages so this is this graph shows the
current treatment strategy for pross
cancer from early local treatment such
as surgery and radiation therapy and
also a lot of patients go through this
hormone therapy or known as antigen
deprivation therapy or ATT but
inevitably these patients that the
countable ADT you will develop a
resistance and big and / CR PC and with
the C RPC emerges
they can the treat the tumor can be
treated with the chemotherapy such as
there are some some text and based
therapies but they only have very short
term benefit for the tumor and
eventually a lot of patients die from
the
there are PC disease so our hypothesis
is that at better stage of the emergence
of the TRP see if we apply a combination
therapy of targeted a drug that can
block MDI see activity but I same time
preserve the t's activity plus a you
military approach potentially we can
reach some level of synergistic advocacy
and then our he limited the tumor or I
believe the controller to Marina states
that it doesn't jeopardize the life of
the patient so that's the basic
hypothesis based on our earlier studies
to test this idea with you know very to
pass the mouse model that the immuno
impact and also on a mechanical to
preclinical trial so we chose this model
the triple nakamoto that the lab
recently published in 2012 this is the
Tripitaka model of deletion of P 10 P 33
and it's meant for in a process of the
mice
so we chose this model because this
model also developed very aggressive
Ross can sir
adenocarcinoma metathesis to laoma
textual info node and also creative
attached to bone and also because the
previous three conditions this model
potentially Harbor more somatic
mutations that can potentially Iitate
adaptive immunity so that's the basic
idea of why we chose this model and then
to help us using the model we actually
incorporate some reporter markers
reporter alleles into the model here are
particularly we bred an optimized with
MTM G allele
time T as well as the lock stop lock to
the sifrits allele so I'm CMT leo allows
only in the process cells are labeled
with GI p where the retinal cells are
tomato popping okay
and the lucifer easily o or will allow
us to specifically
monitor the progression of the Prophet
humor using the non-invasive lumen
symmetry and also we optimized a MRI
imaging approach that we can use the
data to quantify the tumor body so we
optimize all these techniques with this
tool called crypts more mouse model but
we also run into another problem which
is this - model based on these prophets
and Kree allele driver is not easy to
breed because this males have profit
cancer but they have very low upper
comedy so the problem is how can we
overcome this so that we can have a
large cohort or a short period of time
for preclinical tests so we resort in
this new technique called a mouse and
blind stem cell chimeric modeling so
this is a very efficient preclinical
technology that can create a lot of
chimera mice that are you know ready for
drug test so basically the idea is we
have this equipped small Mouse that have
all those alleles that are shown in the
last slide and then we we have those -
and we isolate a stable I brought your
stem cells from those from those mice
and then we inject those are stable
stable and right them they are aligned
into a plastics we answer it from well
type mice particularly to our final p6
mice and then also Komara our plastics
we are developing into our camera mice
that have those no incorporated I
brought them self life and remember
those cell lines will derive from those
tumor promise so genetically they are
also making autumn eyes prone to tumor
prostitue mer development
but because those profits have both this
cells from develop from these cells as
well as from the normal process so
that's why it's called a tomorrow so on
but this is a basic idea we try to
accomplish I know you know we did all
the technical works to make this work
eventually the lower table shows that by
doing so we increase the efficiency of
getting tumor Barry's mail by phone fold
increase that's just only talking about
how many non efficiency forgetting
device per cohort like per liters we
will also save a lot of time so by doing
this we were able to actually test our
idea of combination therapy so so
basically no because of Lisa you know
the result we kind of compared to the
old R to the old attack like you know
not like traditional or conventional
breeding based the gen model within this
new Mouse and brain stem cell based
camera model represents a newer device
that we can further rely on for future
of preclinical test as well so now come
back to the design so as I said we want
to select the drugs that can target I'm
potentially talking to MDS but at same
time preserve T so activity so we kind
of search literature and also to search
for clinical trials and a we found there
are two tyrosine kinase inhibitors one
is called the satiny one is called
couples enemy within a very interesting
the both of Lisa T ki are FDA approved
for treating our other cutter cancer
types but they were have they were
investigated extensively in cross cancer
and actually gone through this one two
three twelve
however they fail all the place to fail
because they could not improve the
overall survival of post cancer patients
with the RPC nevertheless this drugs
proved to be active to regulate a new
cells such as the T cells as well as an
MD Isis
you have the new modular - activity so
we also you know because p10 deletion is
a very frequent improv cancer we also
interesting in testing of a pi3 kinase
I'm fine hitter or we focus on it
inhibitor called PZ 235 police truck is
still in the early exploratory stage
however one paper tests show that this
drug has low toxicity to TCL so we think
like this potentially can also be
combined with on your checkpoint blocker
but we chose that as well so we have
three small compounds that we will test
individually as the model therapy or in
combination with the new checkpoint
blocker and a poem you checkpoint
blockade we use a combination of anti PD
one PDR PDR unhappy diva and anti CPOE
for antibody cocktail
that's our ICP treatment so this slide
shows the overall design of the
preclinical trial so by using the
chimera modeling approach which
generates a whole bunch of these clips
more cameras and then we planted
criteria how to enroll them which is the
mice have to have their profits over 150
cubic millimeter before they turn to 18
weeks out okay so that's our criteria if
the if the camera to meet that criteria
we were in Jordan into our clinical
trial if they don't we will not they
will be excluded from our trial at least
where this modem was measured by weekly
MRI imaging and once we confirm a mouse
is eligible for our clinical trial with
class through the mouse and then we
treat them eyes with we freedom eyes
with the intruder mat is a mixed by art
so this combination treatment of
Constitution Plus in Saluda meant tired
tired or was optimized with our
preliminary data to show can induce
the RPC it is mice it is triple knockout
mice okay so after three weeks we use
MRI image you to confirm the development
of the RPC
in its mouth and it will randomize them
into four group right then the mice will
receive either the control
to the vehicle plus idgi subtype IgG or
the kinase inhibitor or an epidemic
intensity of four ended with the
cocktail as IC b or kinase inhibitor
plus ICP so that you know the single
treatment or combination treatment as a
device or go through bi-weekly
monitoring with MI and after four weeks
they were called go to the and upon
analysis which includes a tumor with
betterment as well as a some histology
and molecular genetics
so that's the basic flow chart of our
experiments so this graph shows the mint
data of bliss starting okay it's the
most important data you can see here the
three graphs here on the left is the
proper weight in the middle is the leaf
on ultimate active on the right is the
Namit acid so you can focus on a
prostate tumor weight chart a loop plot
you will see that neither the ICP or the
drugs as capital aníbal PC or the sin
hip as single therapy either of those
- give me a change the tumor weight
compared to the control okay so neither
of DOMA is sufficient to modify the
tuber however the combination of Cobo
plus IC B or AB easy process it be very
effective to reduce the tumor weight to
very low level okay police was not
observed by the 270 plus ICP treatment
so that's the basic observation anyways
we saw initially that's very exciting to
us hey and this trend also how the true
for our metathesis pretty much except
that in Metaxas we do see that ICP alone
have a high moderate effect to reduce
the metathesis burden but nevertheless
the combination of Cobo + sa b or the pz
+ a is a people the ones that are really
bring the metastasis burden down to
almost zero
so on this result we're showing from the
chimera model from one I brought some
fella and in the paper we also show
another towel I also have similar
results but it's not as you know
specific to a peculiar sterilized it's a
general phenomena in this mod model
so these are some representative with
images of the tumor including primary
prostitute pirata - mer histology as
well as a GMP possible metathesis to
leave a note and - now you can see that
the most effective combination are the
cabo + sa B or the PZ processing
understand what our cause the changes of
the tumor of bile immune cells which
will we use the list technology called
mass photometry or also known as a site
on the list method from listen
technology will allow you to profile our
over 30 surface markers or intracellular
markers at once without the need of
compensation so it's a great technology
so we use this one for our you know
phenotyping and immediately we saw that
the energy chronic treatment with the
sending people of the cuber of optimized
cause almost a complete a depletion of
the intro to Bertie cells including the
total you know both two subtypes
54:34 subset or cd8 subset of t-cell so
this may explain why we don't see any
effect for immunotherapy combination
user because you know you you oblate
t-cells from supermarket Mac environment
and now you try to try an activity see
of course they're not going to be any
effect so this result actually
retrospectively is a consistent with the
previous report showing the seven-year
with inhibiting TCR mediated t-cell
proliferation in a different system so
in the folio studies we focus on the
other two drug that does that
demonstrate accommodation effect so are
you using set of we found that both the
Cobo and the be easy or very effective
to reduce the infiltration frequency of
immediacy and then and also at the same
time they also kind of a boost up the
cd8 positive T cells versus regulatory
t-cell ratio that's already increased by
ICD but equates the further palace kebap
easy treatment ELISA this parameter is
cd8 over Q egg visual was used
frequently to indicate on the defect
positive effect of ICP so this was
increased further ballad to drugs and
then on this job kind of obsessed us
maybe the MDS is compared to either
intensity also all t-cells are more
sensitive to Cobo up easy so to test it
which is use a cell viability is a tool
to measure the variability of these
three populations as we the from the
same tumor to either Cobo up easy as you
can see in the lower part the blue line
represents the MDS is indeed those cells
are most sensitive to the Cobo op is a
treatment so that explains a part of why
they are the most of both pronounced or
impact population in the tumor marking
environment so we know that as this Cabo
and the PZ can reduce the tumor I'm
getting infiltration but what what about
their activity so we answer the MDS is
from user control treaties or the drug
treaty the mice and then we cannot
reduce MDS with a cd4 or cd8 positive T
cells and ask what was the consequence
port for the politics of proliferation
and you can see here if you if you if
you co-culture t-cells with the MDS as
it's actually the form control treaty
the mice this MDS is a very effective to
reduce the proliferation of either TCA
or subset however if you actually the
MDS is from the Cabo or PCA demise those
activities those immunosuppressant
activity was a party lost that means
that not all into this to block reduce
the infiltration VAM disease but also
reduce activity of the MDS six
in summary our cab alternative and
appease it significantly reduce the EPO
tradition and activity of death of MDS
is the question what is the maximum
action for construction time DSC right
so here comes the use of the proteome
proteome profiler array that we are
purchased from our empty systems so the
first leaf here first we want to
understand what's the effect of these
drugs on the the forceful receptor
tyrosine kinase pathway because we know
you know Cabos energy targets some of
the normal RT pays the visa is not
directly targeting our decades but it
can have some indirect consequences
presumably so which one attach so what
happens to tumors after the treatments
using this protein array so you see that
in the four panels we have control of I
beseech with IC be treated or BZ or
couple treaties okay and then you see
that the IC be treated alone doesn't
change much whereas the PZ or Cabo treat
tumors significantly down regulate those
are false or tyrosine signals and we
validate a few of those signals will
also expand our understanding by doing
Western blot of additional markers in
the RTK pathway as well as the pi3k
pathway on the other on the lower right
you'll see that both the couples are
indeed and a bez significantly reduce
the signals for a box by a katie
possible aunt or the false for i six
those are all components of the pi3k
pathway so this result is interesting to
us because recently there have been a
few reports showing that the pi3k
pathway are important from my law itself
to display immune suppressive activity
so you know we kind of install this
again hearing our data we want to
validate the result by - you know
streaming
part of md acid markers a constant with
a marker for PSA k
a downstream report electric circuit
marker here we use the fossilized six as
a marker for active pi3k signaling as
you can see here on the quantification
result on the right the percentage of
ambiences that are positive for four
four five six was reduced dramatically
by either Cabo or PC treatment so this
funding kind of consistent with our
hypothesis that the Cabo op easy
compromise MDA activity through
inhibition pi3k signaling police are
relative so we need to provide some
direct evidence for the idea so we use
this protein transfection method so
ambiences are not easy to manipulate
genetically so but we optimize the
approach that we can use this protein
transaction or method to to have some
impact on the signaling of the MDS is so
here we want to bypass the drug effect
by directly transfect MDS es with the
p70 i6k or r2 so by transfecting these
two proteins or MDS is we hope that we
can bypass the drug effects which are
more like upstream and then turn on the
downstream pathways of the pi3k right
and once we do that we see that the
effect of cobbled Antibes or PZ on the
proliferation by MDS is was relieved
right so now you see that on the right
but on the bar graph you see that when
you treat with capital nib they're all
busy there is a significant reduction of
the proliferation activities viability
of the MDS is but if you if you transfer
the MDS is with these two proteins you
partially rescue the variability of
ambiences despite the treatment of the
drug so that kind of processes are
indeed the ps3 occasionally is at least
partially responsible for reducing the
activity of the variability and I'm
there is another activity of ambiences
in this model well
attendance we want answers okay so now
we know the trucks are hitting their
targets that's kind of expected but I'm
dances are known to be regulated
dramatically by all kinds of federal
crime so dual instructs also have some
effect on federal can is a mapping
environment to understand this we again
use the proteome profiler array from our
D systems this is this time is the
cytokine array so we profile our pins of
cytokines using the tumor lysis from the
control 52 other combination treated and
then we see that here when we begin to
actually use the totality mu plus ICP as
a control as you can see here
pz + SABR Cabo plasticity treatment
altered the level of cytokines of quite
a few of cytokines either decreasing
them or increasing them okay so a few of
the set of cancer decreased by the
combination treatments are known to
regulate MDS is for example zero zero
five fifty forty was unknown to regulate
MDS is positive positive evacuate
immediately
now you reduce them with consistent with
the fact that those combinations reduce
MPSC
on the other hand the rest that are
increased by combination also have some
no activity to regular basis here we
particularly focus on this or one zero
can cause are you looking y ra is ly RA
is a decoy for l1 receptor so
I had no activity to to antagonize I all
want are for one beta activities to the
receptor
so we preserve these MDS in migration I
see to show that MDC are attracted by L
1 R 0 or L 1 beta to migrate straws or
source of tumor tumor signals but if you
treated the system with ly ra you can
block such defect but if you if you use
antibodies that can neutralize L 1 R a
now the attraction of MDS immigration is
recovered so this results suggest that
this combination can regulate the quite
a few of fellow cons and in particularly
can operate with one eye which
internalized il 1 mediated MDS a
migration so so far the data suggests
that those drugs have potentially
directly effect on lamp gases but as we
know no tumor making women that have all
kinds of cells including cancer cells so
very likely those trucks also have some
indirect effect I am DNC to cancer cells
so test this idea with design Lisa your
virtual I see
we actually the prostate cancer cells
from Lisa from Lisa triple knockout mice
right and then we culture themselves
culture those cancer cells and then
treat those cancer cells with either
vehicle or Qabalah PZ and then we
collect the conditioner and then Anna
Warshaw used concentration and a
reconstitution matter to remove those
drugs and knowledge commission media are
pre treated with the drug use compost
condition media - please - culture MDS
is and see what happens to that the SA
the pretreatment with the drugs have any
effect i MDS the activity that's the
basic question so actually the first
thing we saw is even you just use the
conviction media from cancer cells with
all and you drug treatment just
completion media you see that where this
media is very effective to turn on some
of the key proteins are the key genes
expression um deities but that involved
like art arginine depletion or reactive
oxygen species production that is both
SAF one therefore C by P P are all NADPH
oxidase subunits proteins and then those
those things version eternal by
conditioned media from cancer cells but
however if you use consume they are from
the pre treated depends ourselves by the
drug now you see this level of increase
was almost lost
now the condition media condition Minear
lost ability to turn all those
immunosuppressive gene from MDS
and now we use the protocol again use
the setoka proteome provider array to
understand what cytokines are changed by
those pretreatment of drugs on cancer
cells by comparators vehicle trait or
Kabul or PC treated on cognition media
and we see that again quite a few of the
several kinds of change not just single
one quite a few of them okay so you see
that those very know very well known
cytokines that are regular MDM is such
as gm-csf
GCS MTF power of our six those are all
reduced by couple of easy treatment
and then this kind of brought up to the
idea okay so now you are doing and you
are affecting many of those cytokines so
it's not just one of them
so to show that those cytokines can
collectively affect the MDS activity so
we actually use the recombinant that
accounts for all those change change
instead of cons and then put it back
into the country media and show that now
the expression of those important immune
suppressive genes are partly recovered
when you treat the constitute media we
kind of supplement those condition media
with with the individuals etiquette so
this gives us a conclusion that the
drugs the BZ and Kabul not only in
affected MDS it directly but also affect
what cytokines are secreted by cancer
cells by reducing the secretion of a pro
pro MD IC penalize those drugs also
reduce the ability of cancer cells to
promote MDS in a Mac environment lastly
we want to we were proved to use the
additional drug to show that the pi3k as
the type of specific drugs also can
collaborate with IC b to induce
synergistic Africa efficacy so here we
use two PS making emitters and isotypes
disability hitters why is the p1 10 data
transmitter when the humans in beta for
a cleaner both and also we tried our new
clock or called sx6 84-82 that's a
survey r1 2 inhibitor from this company
and then because we know that these
models the sense they are once they are
to
signaling is crucial for recruiting them
of MDS it to the Mac environment so we
call similarly to what I show earlier we
either treat the CR PC with single drug
of each of this osa be all with to the
combination treatment you see that we
again we see that accommodation of the
of the SS form specific emitter
very effective I will combine with ICT
to elicit a significant as a tumor
effect of policy RPC and this was also
seen with the sensi r12 inhibitor in
combination with ICD
so finally we collect some clinical
evidence to support that the granular
satyam nest we have a lot of unit tumor
also relevant in human cancer and they
also reversely curl it with cd8 positive
T cells so these are data from fine
needle purposes the fresh tumors that
come from the clinic
so this reverse correlation between
grand you know setting objectives and
the cd8 positive T cells in the clinical
further cooperate but the idea that no
we come from the mouse model because the
normal model we also have listened
inward correlation we also have the
trick granular setting and yes as
donating population of I'm deities we
also solve it in a clinical sample
so in summary by using a new mouse model
and then on and then a accommodation for
ICP with cannon interest we show that
for resistant tumors for tumors are
resistant to immunotherapy and
immunotherapy you need to have
combinations of activity or activity
drugs such as entropy diva at the city
level and a PDL one but you also need
regions that can supposedly suppress MDS
es such as the pi3k invaders or the cell
fearfully hitters in order to remove
those negative effect on t-cells if you
only knew what those will not be
effective but if you do them together
your proper way you will be able to
elicit strong anti-cancer synergistic
effect so this paper was published the
earlier in 2017
and now my lab is continuing on this
direction to understand the deeper how
MDS is regulated t-cells particularly we
have been focusing our whole MDS is
about producing our s and RS to modify
t-cells as the penis that is very
important the proteins on T cells so
that they can have a new mechanism when
we give a new mechanism hi I'm Jesse
regulate the TCR
so finally I'd like to thank our all
people who made this project possible
including my previous of mentor dr.
ronald opinion a dr. Alan Wong as MDS
I'm the energon Cancer Center I also
want to thank my current lab members and
also my wonderful collaborators are at
MD Anderson as well as Notre Dame and
Indiana University I want to thank all
the funding agencies that attract them
on my research and then together we can
make kinds of research better we can be
eventually help a lot of cancer patients
you
Thank You dr. Luo for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box dr. Luo as well as biotech
new scientist and a revert will answer
as many questions as time permits and
our first question is for you dr. Shen
how do you calculate how a biosimilar
binds to VEGF
oh hi our so to calculate a biosimilar
binding to VEGF I think this is our
biophysical biophysical questions so I'm
assuming the audience is talking about a
pure compound appending to a purified of
EEG I have in common a protein for
instance in this case I person don't
have too much experience on this I say
but I think something like a surface
plasmon resonance assays using the
alcohol from GE is a good solution to
this so but I really wanted directly to
like some expert who has more experience
in physical opening IOC's which I do not
have so yeah thank you okay have you
tested other pi3k isoforms alpha beta
delta gamma selective inhibitors yeah
this is compressed
not with effort and then I'll give you
the second part
yes so good question you see that
throughout the end of the presentation
we did it
taxi the two pi3k isoform Hebron and
both of them did a show our impressive
combination effect when combined with
the immunotherapy so there are also a
two back to back the nature papers
published later last year suggesting
3-kinase gamma inhibitors also are can
hibbott myeloid cells and they are
surgery as well within your therapy so
it's kind of in line with our reports so
uh so that you know that's kind of
austere in the first question yes with
these other people also did the
selective inhibitors are believed to be
better than these pine hitters because
they are more selective and more it's
the business fig and so the second part
of the same question is isn't a parent
pi3k inhibitor toxic to t cell survival
so the the the hibbett er we use easy to
35 at high concentration is toxic to the
cells but I said um we actually select
this particular one because based on
paper a freak and all that papers
earlier in publish the data showing that
least Lisa Hitler is generally tolerated
by T cells so that's why we chose this
one so we don't entirely know why Lisa
Hitler is not inhibiting T cells as one
would expect but it has low arm toxicity
to T cells but but that's a good
question because there is a concern on
using high dose of pi3k Hitler would
affect the TCO activity that that's why
I think when you're designing current
combinations is important to reach like
a greater window of dosing and then so
that it can inhibit
MDRC enough are the same same time
largely preserved activity of T cells so
if you use the very high dose for the
driver yes you I think in principle you
will inhibit T cells altogether how do
you define development of castrate
resistance in a CPP SML mouse why I'm
sorry I didn't get too much time to
characterize this part in the inner
presentation so basically for this model
of the valley's model or we do this
combination treatment at first so we did
the our castration a surgical castration
remove the testicle of the mice so there
is a very little residual like supply
off for energy through the body of the
mice at same time we use the Instituto
mine which is the 2nd generation engine
receptor inhibitor to totally shut down
the AR signaling so by doing this
together we believe on we we removed all
the signaling from engine engine and
there are mimics the energy provision
therapy in the clinic and then and once
we do that in this mouse model
Oh in the first week when we
to imaging following up the tumor volume
of bioluminescence imaging following
after tumors the signals from the tumors
you will see a job we thought with our
job of the signals we saw drop of the
tumor volume but the tumors quickly
catch up in three weeks after in a based
on imaging results and then we think
that this is again consistent with a lot
of clinical observations and write a few
other mouse model that's based on pita
and division there is an immediate
effect from I ADT in the mouse models as
well as in the clinic the problem is
leads the emergence of the resistance
and then we define this because we saw
Lisa or relapse of the you know kind of
a reef growth of the tumor of bigger
than orange nose eyes before the
surgical castration and an internet
Institute of minor treatment so that's
how we define the C RPC and then again
here I just want to address that we
define this part based on a primary
tumor or we know we don't have the
resolution to detect the metathesis to
call whether this is a CRP C or not so
the fact that they do exist liz menezes
the to developer after all these
treatments suggesting they are resistant
to such engine or supply on removal and
then on cutting so so we believe what
they are say our pcs dictate you know
they can be defined a metastasis ERP C
but we don't have of like a tracking for
the metastasis or through the whole
process for metastasis we are looking at
any point for primary tumor we do have
data to track the the process and then
know there is a involvement and a
emergence of the of the of them of the
CRP see yeah thank you
have you looked at combinations with PD
one or ctla4 separately and not just in
noon checkpoint blockade and what was
the rationale for using immune
checkpoint blockade
good question so in the paper with the
Renata separates 8p1 CTR for treatment
we use them together you know cocktail
one of the reasons was is because that
ctla4 alone was not effective for the
clinical use in a protocol of the most
cancer based on reports and there are
and that's why we kind of want to use
this combination to start with and at
the present we didn't see you mean the
combination didn't work well that's why
we we kind of constantly use
consistently use these the combination
of PTSD do inference about these as I
see be used in the paper and a later we
did separate them we particularly it has
the pdy antibodies which is a kind of
more popular or fall kind of all you
know therapy treatment nowadays so we
use the PD Vallon law in combination
with the MDI t targeting agent and we
also saw a similar level of aqua
synergistic effect we didn't you call
that in paper will do that those who are
done later after after the paper also
accepted but we did separate them and
the NPD one anybody alone also have
pretty strong exactly when we use
together with I'm desi targeting drug
why is the MDS C effect minimal when you
have a strong effect in proliferation as
a capo sedative and be easy
you
uhh
so efficiency so uh why I'm not entirely
sure about these questions referring to
but I can answer to my best
it's a I think one moment when liable to
understand is we do leads I say to
measure the sensitivity of for the men
cell populations we care most from this
tumor to cancer cells MD Isis and T
cells a measure their response
respectively to either couple treatment
or PD treatment you know those dependent
matter in ritual that's what we did and
we saw that MDS is the most sensitive
you can you know and certain
constitutions that you already kill all
the MDS C's well you are the intensity
also t-cells are still alive so that's
kind of the basic observation we had and
then we always that's what we reported
and there are with at least movement we
don't entirely sure why why I'm deities
are most insensitive because there are
so many answers so many possibilities
and why one cell type is more sensible
to one drug compared to other cell types
so me so potentially is you know the top
is the most straightforward possible
answer is that on the MDS is rely on the
pathways that are inhibited by those
drugs more there are other cells like
cancer cells or T cells that we test it
so but okay and those constants also is
kind of a philosophical answer is not a
mechanistic answer so we are in the
process of categorizing deeper on why
I'm deficits are sensitive to certain
pi3k inhibitors compared to other cell
types right now and then hopefully can
come back with better answers in your
future great and the next one is for you
and for Anna and it's a three parter so
how about if I read the whole thing and
then you can you know let me know if you
need me to read you know question two in
question three again one of the knockout
in the
chimeric mice mentioned was mad for does
tgf-beta play a role in development of
MDS C and why tgf-beta why was tgf-beta
not measured in the cytokine panel so
again the first part
is one of the knockout in the chimeric
mice mentioned was mad for does tgf-beta
play a role in the development of MDF
see yes so a simple question so on so
the mouse model we have used here have a
cement for or in conjunction with pizza
and tv3
lots of function all in the most profit
the basically not in other cells or
tissues so that means we do not perturb
the SMED signaling in my law itself
including MDS so so we did not know no
deleted mana for yourself so those
pathways if we important are still
intact than the MDS is so so so so far I
think that the reports are tgf-beta
signaling or BMP signaling through SMED
pathways or MDS see differentiation or
functions is limited but that's a good
question I think that's definitely good
into test because tgf-beta signaling
seems to be pretty like heavily strong
immunosuppressive activity in various
aspects on T cell immunity if we found
that PC or tgf-beta signaling is also
involved in MDS I'll be very interesting
and kind of will provide more insight
how we can design better immuno
therapeutics based on targeting tgf-beta
signaling that's a very good question a
very good direction to explore further
so the second part of the question why
do beta is not measured in a set of n
all right so I don't think I see T of
beta refer guys included in this stuff
in the Ferger
array panel but you know apparently if
well you know it should be included for
all the gradients will be available soon
so it should it should be included
because it's so important and would you
like to weigh on this one in on this one
too and let me know if you need me to
read any part of it over again no the
only part I would say is that the reason
why tgf-beta wasn't measured on the
cytokine panel is because it's not
included in the cytokine panel most
likely because there was a cross
reactivity if
with other contents so you would have to
follow a follow up with a different
method either traditional Western or
q-kidz or something like that
okay and Nephilim is for you dr. Shen in
your view which pi3k
isoform is driving MD SC inhibition and
is the p10 deficiency dependent is this
p10 deficiency dependent
also uh so for that question of which
pi3k isoforms as I said there were on
two back-to-back papers reporting pi3k
gamma is a essential form for MDS for
MDRC or md80 like even though
suppressing myeloid cells in different
mouse models so are and those two papers
well I think at least one of them is
based on knockout starting so it's
pretty definitive or addressing this
question and then I don't necessarily
know whether our other isoforms rather
besides gamma is also essential with our
data using inhibitors it seems to be
also very important but the inhibitors
are generally not as definitive as of
providing genetic evidence so we don't
have genetic evidence to knock out
different isoforms of pi3k you know MDS
a lineage to answer this question or
definitively so I think you know this is
something that I'm way others in the
field to the to just to specifically
knock off yesterday hitters it's ps3 ps3
ki so problems in the you know MT ICD
age and that has to better and on which
as a form is most important now maybe
commentate what Brooks together or maybe
wines are more important than others
above questions the whole do it because
so far there's no like MD Isis
specifically or something you can use to
turn into a condition knockout in its
lineage so I something I can still some
technical challenge there but I think
it's something that people should work
on including off and there are second as
part of questions are
is uh sorry what's the second part of
question do you think there are
differences
Arthur form on sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I move that question over hang on one
second in review which pi3k isoform is
driving NBS a division and is this
keikain deficiency dependent pittance
sorry yes the second part is the pit and
deficient dependent again so in a mock
model the p10 is on the cancer cells not
on the MDS es so
I think you know mbit/s as we show the
ps3 facing them is important and there
are weather that driven by pittin
loss-of-function are apparently unlikely
to be genetically called about by that
because I'm deities I don't think they
have a pittance deviations in them no
matter is in the experimental system or
in clinical samples so but again p10 can
be regulated by many different levels
including like you know silencing of the
transcription so to MDS they have a
lower level of Peter and compared to on
normal myeloid cells possibly with
pigeon has that but that's a good
question I think if it we test and I
turn out to be true it could explain a
partly why di circuit hyperactivity
human disease which cells do use like
MDS see in your ass a human mouth and do
you think there are differences yeah so
in our ices and I believe most of the
like Isis publishing papers people use
Mouse I'm diocese this em deities can
include a CDL NB g r1 positive cells or
there are subsets as reason from either
the spring or the tumor itself from most
models of cancer enough first we
actually time deities from tumors using
our military kids and there are a no way
to know so far we have not used i'm
dance acid from humans because the
humans is a still controversial what's
the best markers to use to identify MDS
and then there are papers that have done
that to isolate and i'm DSC like cells
from humans and then they do shows those
cells also surprise t-cells
so you can get on search those papers
and then and then see how they do it so
there are combination markers at 3:33
like 30 45 ohio city of a city of 14 hi
all cities 15 hi depending on which type
of population you use and also also
although cells have HLA t our logo so
that can be having low
Oh image 3 class to our mechanism to
present antigens that's not their main
function I guess so but they have a
specific markers they use but again the
field is still debating what's the best
marker to use as is human MPS's so I'm
sure there are the differences between
I'm human and mouse ambiences if you
look at the molecular back details but
again so remember we define the answer
using functional assays if you actually
the population of Milo itself during
tumor development and can surprise
people you can call the MDS es if you're
on that level I think they are say right
functionally they are the same an
overall picking but once you look into
deeper mechanisms and articulate what
genes are expressed in each population
which part is enriched I'm sure you will
see a lot of differences and it looks
like we have time for one more question
is MDS C infiltrate related to peak and
loss in CRP see similar to how others
have shown four kills and pekin in
melanoma
ah yes so uh I'm guessing if you trade
in you see RPC so there's a recent paper
or coming up published from a City of
Hope or Cooper from City of Hope sure
that MD SCS
are correlated increase of mdac you feel
trillion correlated with the a/c RPC
development and there are so far there
are not too many papers started I'm
there see infiltration in proc cancer
yes that's one paper and are we look at
actually as I said with reporting the
paper our assembles are not at the RPC
the fume assemble the north the RPC
those are a primary like a untreated an
achievement naive human prostate tumors
tumor samples so we don't have data to
know how much I'm there the infiltration
is the MDS II and we don't know either
whether it's correlated with peat and
division so and also I'm sorry I don't
have data to compare that with the
Till's of heating standards in melanoma
so in melanoma there are reports to show
MDS they also infiltrate but again
melanoma generally respond well to
immunotherapy of probably sex to their
high you know Jeannie City so uh so for
melanoma MDS II may not be as potent as
in prostate cancer that but that's just
my speculation I don't have a data to
back up that thank you I would like to
once again thank dr. Lou for his
presentation do you have any final
comments
we are yeah so I really appreciate this
opportunity to present our story and
then as I said we are in the in my new
lab at nor dam we are in the process of
catalyzing several different the front
of you know MDS II and further
understand how they surprised these
cells and one particular thing is that
we look at it and then recently found
MDS it can induce like a lot of protein
or post translational modifications in T
cells in particular protein nitrogen in
T cells so we're trying to finish the
story and then try to report to the
field and then I think I'm the ICS are
certainly very important for kinda
immunotherapy and then more and more
people realize this and then there are a
lot of interest in developing their
abilities against MDS as well in the
pharmaceutical company
so using like protein profilers are one
of the best tools to start those because
they are so heavily relying on cytokines
for their functions so yeah okay thank
you so much for opportunity and I would
love to participate in similar
opportunities in your future well thank
you again very much and I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor biotech me for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD tab at the top right and
follow the process to receive your
credits this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through July 2018 lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye